la ciudad de las luces de nuevo en
llamas
los manifestantes salieron a las calles
de París por noveno día consecutivo este
jueves y al caer la noche Se registraron
incidentes violentos
a primera hora más de un millón de
manifestantes en su mayoría pacíficos
marcharon por toda Francia
indignados no solo por la reforma de las
pensiones que ampliará la jubilación de
los 62 años a los 64 sino también por el
uso de poderes especiales por parte del
presidente la semana pasada que forzó la
aprobación del proyecto de ley sin el
voto de la asamblea nacional
el gobierno ha aprobado esta ley con un
poder que le permite la constitución
pero mi generación nunca votó por esta
Constitución no está bien Queremos otras
formas de gobierno algo que sea legal el
procedimiento del 49.3 no es legítimo
ante el depósito de petróleo de
estibadores y sindicalistas de la cgt se
manifestaron luego que las autoridades
los intentaran obligar a volver al
trabajo el suministro de queroseno en la
capital se encuentra bajo mínimos los
políticos también salieron a la calle el
líder del partido verde lanzó flores a
las fuerzas de seguridad para denunciar
la violencia mundial
amnistía internacional ya manifestado su
preocupación por el uso excesivo de la
fuerza y las detenciones arbitrarias
algo de lo que se hace eco la alianza
parlamentaria de izquierda nupes
una tenemos una deriva autoritaria no es
Polonia no es un guía pero los
republicanos en su conjunto están
derivando hacia la derecha lo que es
extremadamente preocupante
los sindicatos ya han convocado nuevas
huelgas y protestas para el martes que
podrían perturbar una visita prevista
del Rey británico Carlos a tercero